Yep. Alright. Hey, what's going on?
It's bill burr and uh, it's time
for not a Monday morning podcast,
a very special Monday morning podcast.
Some of you who listen to this
show every week, you know,
every once in a while I'll have a good
friend come on and a will bullshit.
No commercials, no nothing. And uh,
this time I'm going good friend.
You are the good friends. I like
that thick. They were where we came.
We had a set relationship we did that was
supposed to then evolve into some sort
of dinner that we never had
hospitals we yet know yet.
I'm still holding out and I'm still
holding out hope staring out the window.
And Ladies and gentlemen, Steven
Brill, we have here a Steve Brill,
the director of a movie that I uh,
I was fortunate enough to have a very
small part in coming up this weekend.
May 2nd walk of shame
starring Elizabeth Banks. Yes.
And James Marsden,
who pizza probably saw an anchorman two.
Well good ma'am.
You don't have a small part in it though.
There are no small parts.
There's only
insecure performance,
which you are not cut out of the movie.
There are those, you know,
I cut my grandmother out,
I swear to God.
Well you weren't there,
but my wife's grandmother
who's 90 years old, uh,
I put her in at the very end.
It was a very cool touching thing to do
and she's a performer and she'd never
been in a movie. And so you acted like
her dream was going to come true? We did.
We flew her down and you know,
it was like queen for a day and she was
really into it and I haven't told her
she's cut out the, oh no. How
are you going to know it? Well,
she was nice, so I was
like, Eh, uh, but uh,
so we got to look me
up. No, absolutely not.
But part of me was like,
this isn't the most pressing thing.
And then all of a sudden it's
coming out and she doesn't know. Oh,
because you have to go through the whole
all the promotion things and edit it
down and run it before. I just don't know.
It's been cut for a while. I have not,
I should have told her or I should.
And then I, my wife went up there,
she lives in Marine County and I told my
wife to tell her and my wife chickened
out, so she doesn't know. But I got
a call or shoot kind of chicken out.
You kind of ponder it off. I totally
pawn it off on her, but uh, it's, uh,
yeah, it's, it's something I gotta
deal with. Ah, that's my life.
What are you going to do?
You're just going to let the chips fall
where they may could because she sorta
lives in their own world up there.
She's a dance instructor on a hilltop.
Shit's not going to play up there.
But she might have a friend who go,
I saw the movie and, uh, where were
you? What, what if you just deny it?
I could do, I could do that. Oh my God.
Literally see the stress
on your face. Oh, you know,
it's happened a lot and often you
do movies and you cut parts, uh,
that people love, uh, and you,
you tell them and sometimes you
cut an entire performances and uh,
it's the director no one else should do
at the director should man up and it,
and I tend to do it, but in this case
I haven't done it. What's the worst?
And I have to, I'm sorry.
Thank you for having me. You,
you are cut from the movie bill.
You are completely cut
this guy here coming across the table.
What's the, uh, I don't want you,
if you don't want to name names,
but what's the worst situation that
you've had where you had to cut an entire
performance? The worst reaction though,
like maybe the first time he had to do it,
like how long did it take you to get
the balls up to just call them up and be
like, Hey, maybe that dream you had.
Remember how about how I told you,
oh,
well you were doing in the movie and
you're really making this and how it's
going to do stuff for your career.
Well, yeah. Oh my guys. See,
I'm trying to think of a very particular
incident. It happens all the time.
It's happened to me as an actor too.
I was an actor and many
actors he'll talk to,
we'll go through your experience of,
uh, showing up to the premier almost,
or sitting around the TV with their
family and going, okay, here I come.
Here I come.
And then they skip the part of the
narrative where they're supposed to be.
And it's like the worst experience
that I've been to a premiere.
I was cut out and the director didn't
tell me what it was a small part.
And I vowed never to do that. Of course,
now I'm doing it with my grandmother, but,
uh,
I can't remember she lives,
but I'm uh, uh, I have cut.
I have cut great scenes from people
that I thought that we just couldn't,
we couldn't keep it in the movie and
they were really bummed out about that.
It's a great scene. They've done a great
job. It's just that films too long.
The pacing, what, what is it? Yeah, it's,
it's emotional scenes
generally in a comedy.
Like I'll usually put a few emotional
scenes in that might not be,
not have enough jokes or even any jokes.
And there's a movie I did called late
last night, which is a movie I wrote. Um,
and it started to Emilio Estefan as in
Steven Weber and it was all about two
guys at night.
It wasn't dissimilar from this movie
of shame was two guys one night,
La losing their minds.
And they had this one critical scene
where they sat and they really talked it
out about three quarters of
the way through the movie.
And one guy talked about sort of, you
know, where all his problems come from.
And there was a mention of a girlfriend
dying of aids and there was a whole
monologue store,
but it was good.
It was really long tracking shot
through a sand in the bunker.
They were in a golf course at night
and it was sort of telling everything I
thought I wanted to write the movie about,
which is often a mistake is when
you have people talk about it.
And a well performed.
Emilio cried and we were all so
proud of ourselves afterwards.
And then we just started, I cut it into
the movie and it was just like, okay,
here comes that scene everybody.
Oh. And it shows the dragon.
The audience didn't like it.
Test audiences. Uh, anybody
who saw it was like, okay,
well played, but actually sticks out
as being a little, not pretentious,
but unnecessary and overstating
the themes of the movie obviously.
And it looks better without, did you
fight for the scene or you just know?
I the only one who, it was my movie. I
didn't have a lot of pressure on me. Uh,
so I, I, I cut up myself and then
told them and they were, it was a,
it was an actor's moment.
And certainly when you send the script,
a lot of actors get very attracted
to certain scenes in movies.
I don't know if you get
that and you're like,
that's why a lot of movies attracted
to the fact that I'm actually in one,
but there's a plane ticket for you. Just
happy to be the Kona New Orleans. Yeah,
I'll fly myself there. Absolutely.
Well as it moves along, you'll,
you'll read a script you and be like,
oh, that moment, uh, that's a good one.
And then often sometimes you don't even
shoot that moment or it gets co opted or
a director will go, oh, that line, uh,
uh, I think the other guy should say that.
And then you'll take that one.
That happens a lot,
like just certain moments
or beats get switched.
Sometimes you just have to roll with
it. Just like being cut. And I, I,
since I feel I've been cut and
I sort of live in the Rio, uh,
I've been at the business a long time,
so I'm pretty pragmatic
about Hollywood and that's,
I don't even tell my parents until
jobs are almost shooting, you know,
because things fall apart so much out
here and I don't say shit. I exactly,
until I started promoting this movie
like two weeks in that I'm still thinking
like, well, I know, I'm trying to think.
I was trying to think of a way that
you could cut me out and I came up with
three different ways you could do it.
So it was just like going,
I don't want to be that guy cause you
know I already get trashed enough on
Twitter. Oh really? It's just me trying
to read out loud and stuff. I, I get,
I give them plenty of material on my own.
The last thing I needed to do was say
that I'm in a movie that I'm not in.
Oh my gosh. Because I've always wanted
this. If the actor gets cut out,
can, can he still get the footage
for is real. That often happens.
And I like to say yes and
then I'm never able to do it.
So it's a double whammy because I'm like,
well,
because generally I don't own the
footage in the studio. We'll be like,
why would you want a,
unless it's a pure outtake that often
we can put the outtakes on the DVD of a
scene, which happened that saved us on a
few and a few incidents where, you know,
we'd put the extra scenes, see, so the,
the, you'd always be able to put it on,
but often people would want their stuff
and I wasn't allowed to release it.
So dude,
I know a guy who he had like five
scenes with Al Pachino in a movie.
What movie?
I don't know the movie,
but I saw the pain in his eyes
that I know it was a real story.
He told everybody and they showed up.
Oh yeah.
It was one of those stories he's telling
me and I'm just like going, Oh God, bail,
bail, take, take, take an exit.
And he just rode the
wave to the beach and uh,
they cut the entire storyline.
Oh yeah. It just is.
When they went to go pick, put it
like, I don't know how you guys do.
Like I have such fucking add,
like that's why standup is perfect for me.
It's like, oh, I have an idea and I talk
about it for 90 seconds and I'm like, Ooh,
look at that light that just came on.
And then I go over there like I've tried
to write scripts and it goes well to
about page 30 and it starts spinning
out of control and I go into denial and
I'll get to about page 50 then
I'm just like, ah, this is just a,
it's like a giant pizza dough that just
out of control and it's a virtual wall.
You hit and you back back away from it
and Jesus shows up and he kills everybody
except for the hero and the end
page 60. Yeah. Not a script. Yeah,
it's so capricious. Is that the word,
the movie business things or you know,
I was going to say you are award shows
right on the tip of my tongue, but I like,
I like it reflects your pension.
Yes. It's so crucial. Uh,
the uh, yeah, the I stories.
I've been around a lot of actors
too and there was a story,
I'll tell this story because
no ones knows this story.
It's so crazy about what can
happen to you as an actor.
Is this the actors podcast,
by the way, believe me,
if your people are not into this,
right so far,
we're going to talk about the movie and
then we'll get on to sports because got
to go to sports. Yeah. I would say
out of all the directors in Hollywood,
you have the best throwing arm.
Oh, thank you, dude. It was insane.
Remember that day we was
throwing the football around,
we will doing something and had a
helicopter or CIA seed and you're like,
all right, I'm going to throw it, you
know, and you, you know, no offense,
but you know,
you sit there and share the puree on.
I can't throw a ball guys
throwing it all over.
He's Dhamaka Bill. All right. Yeah.
Thanks. [inaudible] Hollywood. Yeah,
of course. It was it a pink
one too, for breast cancer.
How many levels that I people,
I can't believe a Beretta bad
that I call it a little. No,
we, that's what it is. Yeah. It's,
I forget what I called MCI Yarmulke.
It's money if you're balding
places to clip it on to go. Yeah, they
do. I don't tape it. I don't know. I got,
I got nothing on yama cause I mean I,
all right,
well tell us about this movie comes
out. It comes out, uh, May 2nd,
which is this Friday. This Friday.
Okay. So this movie comes out,
uh,
on,
it's this new thing they do with movies
where you can actually buy it on iTunes
through the same day it comes out.
Did you know that? No, I didn't. Yeah.
Vod Dane date.
So I think that's really smart because
people basically have movie theaters in
their homes with the surround sound.
That is what's happened.
And there's certain movies have
caught the idea that it's going to,
cause you don't have to
deal with people talking.
If they are talking to the man of the
house, you tell him to shut the fuck up.
You don't have to worry about
getting a job broken. Right.
And if you watch it alone, you can. Yes.
Schizophrenia takes up, shut the fuck up.
Um, this, uh, is, yeah,
so it comes out that gives you the
option of seeing it in theaters.
If you like the theater experience,
and I love the theater.
He sticky floors, you can,
you can go and, but look,
I mean you got to ask yourself,
why are movies getting so big and crazy
and why is it all special effects and
three d it is because they have got to
get people away from their 60 inches.
Right? Which is really what it is now you
can buy a 60 inch TV for three grand or
something,
a great one and people are not going
to leave their house and go through the
whole thing unless it's, you know, they
don't think they can get that experience.
So to that end movies like
cars is not in three days.
It has cinematic touches that
you really want to, you know,
appreciate in the cinema. But seeing it
at home is not a bad way to do it either.
So, but you have the choice comes out
May 2nd in theaters and Vod and model.
I had a, I had such a great time
on that. I got to work with the,
I never met before. People might
know him from a, what was that?
American history JAKKS American history x.
The white man marches on.
He sang that song. Yeah. Yeah.
I used to sing that to my black friends
when they didn't pick up their phone in
the 90s. I would sing that to
their, their aunts for sheets.
So plea, uh, who is, uh, my
name is [inaudible]. Yeah,
my name is Earl. My name
and uh, well he was just in,
we'll will fall street. We saw him in
the Wall Street. He, man, he's the best,
I think he's like, he's not underrated.
People know who he is and stuff,
but I think he's the funniest.
I used them in this movie called
without a paddle like 10 years ago.
He went to New Zealand when I hung
out with them for months there.
And he was just the best and the funniest
part told that great scene where he,
he didn't want to point
the gun at somebody and you
guys had this epic screaming
match at each other and some of the
forest in the middle of Louisiana.
That's true. He's also very
peculiar, as accurate as can be,
even though he's very sort of straight
forward and easy to deal with.
He decided his character. That's
what I was, he decided to,
his character had changed.
Three is a bad guy.
He thought his character going through
an arc where you'd actually internally
changed his feelings towards the guy who
was chasing and had ambivalence about
shooting him. So he wouldn't
point the gun at him at the end.
I see me literally
wouldn't raise it going up.
He had a tip down sort of at
his crotch. And uh, I was like,
he thinks he had gone up,
gone up. I thought it was
just being lazy. And he goes,
I can't man. I go, what
are you talking about?
You gotta train your weapon on these guys.
And you're like in the bush,
in the middle of the woods in New
Zealand where you could only access to by
helicopter. Burt Reynolds is there.
It's, it's a crazy, surreal scene.
And he's decided that his character's
gone through some sort of character arc
where he's nonviolent to the point of
like, you know, we'll let them run away.
And that was not in the script
and that was not intended. And he,
but if you do see the movie,
he won because he just
would not tip his weapon up.
And I gave up on him. Yeah. He said, you
edited in a completely different gun.
That's true. Yeah. Which is
the directors. That's right.
I remember looking at it and I see it
as a game, so I was like, okay buddy,
you want to do that?
So I think I got like a commando or
some Schwartzenegger movie and found a
closeup of a gun that matched his gun
and he just did a close up my bed being
cocked and loaded and then
do close up of his face.
So it looked like he was
ready to kill these people.
What would I love about that story
is so fun. Guys argued so bad.
And then you guys were total
friends. Oh yeah. On the set.
So I looked at it like when Tom Brady
yells at his offensive coordinator and
then the end of the game you're like, ah,
you know, you're still friends and then,
yeah. Yeah. I think that's, I do
operate on an aggressive sort of,
let's work this year. I remember, uh,
when we were filming that the Superbowl
was yeah. And while we were shooting.
Yeah. You had some, uh, you know, you'll
throw a little money down. I will. Yeah.
I lost that super bowl. I know
that I had Baltimore, right. Oh,
at nine or no? Second
half. Oh, this the ravens.
I actually picked the ravens last year.
How'd you do this year? Uh, overall. Yeah,
a loser. I mean, anyone who says they win
is a liar. Honest gambler. I, yeah, yeah,
yeah. No, I was overall a loser and a
in football. A, what was the Superbowl?
Seattle. Uh, oh yeah. I had
Broncos fed against Peyton. Me.
I mean, I wouldn't know anyone. It's
like gambler of course. As a, as a, as a,
I don't know why. Did you
hate, you hate Peyton or no,
I just felt that Seattle had
that kind of defense. Yeah.
That pisses him off where
he gets frustrated, right.
Where they're really
physical with his receivers.
Basically the whole thing that caused
him and Jim or say to make that tape
against the Patriots. I know a bunch
of cold fans are rolling their eyes,
but that's what the fuck happened.
So I felt like if they stopped him
enough early on, he would get frustrated.
But none of that even happened. No,
just snap the ball over his head.
And I know the wheels fell off all over
the place, so I don't put like that loss,
you know, on him. It was just like,
I just think the first play went so
bad and then the pressure of the game,
because Seattle wasn't that
much better than the Broncos.
I definitely think that they were
the better team, but that was,
remember the member,
the 80s when there was just like three
Superbowls in a row where it was just an
absolute blowout.
Yeah.
It started as a game and then one
team got out, goes over San Diego.
I mean nine years over San
Diego. Yeah, that, that run.
And that's 99 I was talking more like a,
I would say Cincinnati,
no Raiders destroying the red skins.
49 is came back and stopped and said,
bears destroying the Patriots. Yeah.
Giants destroying the Broncos.
Redskins destroying the Broncos than
the 49 bangles was a good one. Right.
And then you went into the buffalo years.
It was just really like close, terrible.
And they got good. Yeah. It was
kind of like, yeah, it was wild.
It was really like globe trotters,
Washington generally,
but like almost like a decade. I remember
like, uh, players from other sports,
what somebody big and another sports was
like, like, why would you even watch it?
It's like a blow out every year. And it
was like literally eight of the 10 years.
It was like 44 to 10,
56 to three, you know,
we're still really bad at first one was
the Saint Louis where he tackled him on
the two Tennessee St Louis. That
makes fun. Started or run, sorry,
start us at the game. Uh, where they were.
London Fletcher got him on the two. Yup.
That was 99. And then, uh,
I started a run where all of a
sudden the Superbowl was awesome.
2000 Raven's dominated the giants and
then all the Patriots ones were close.
And then the fucking best was a,
was a Broncos.
Packers that, oh yeah, I was
at that one. That was great.
That was down in San Diego,
in San Diego.
I remember thinking about going to that
game and I was watching the game and
when La dove headfirst and helicopter
around, I said to my friend, I said,
if they win this game, right, that is in
every highlight reel, I'll Superbowls.
And when they did the John Elway,
that was the greatest.
I was right there for that.
I was literally right there,
second row from the top of the stadium.
It was literally like so far away
that shithole stating that stain.
But it's a dump, I guess. I mean,
you know. Yeah, it is. It is right.
I've seen all ice to work. Uh, I how,
make sure it always, you've been to,
let's go there.
I've only been at Psu.
I went to [inaudible] age
of AC for 80 fucking no,
and it bled so night in New Orleans.
That was what you just said was
exactly what I was going to say.
Fucking bled Saul loss.
Cause that fucking asshole pat
sells fucking sold his house.
That up baby. Yep. No, you
wouldn't be due to fucking dinner.
You'll cook the meal.
You got to let me buy the groceries.
Well that was one of the
most self centered fucking
things. It's like, all right,
you don't get along with the owner sees
so fuck the whole team. I know. Right.
And he was,
he was a good enough coach and had a good
enough team where we were in it until,
uh, it was a mid, oh, I
think it was the first half.
We were still in it despite that bullshit.
Then there was the return that Michigan
kid ran it back and that was at an end
zone seats and he was standing
right at us. And then the next one,
the next one that I went to was a, I went
to when, when? When we beat the rams.
Yeah. Yup. And when, uh, when
they kicked the field goal,
I was on the opposite and they kicked
it. Right. Right. The other way I baked,
you know, that's the kind of hookup I,
yeah. I have upper deck end zone seats,
but I, you know, I went to
them and I ended up, uh,
when we went played the
next super bowl after that,
which I the fuck did we play after that?
It was either the eagles, there was no,
it was the, uh, the pants, the Superbowl,
the panthers and I had
an opportunity to go,
but then I got called in
to do the Chappelle show,
world series at dice for fans of the
show that was taped like the day before
super bowl Sunday or the day
after. Like I, I couldn't make it.
And I remember being upset that
I wasn't able to go, but say,
cause I got acting work right.
And then the second that game was over,
even though we won the fact that I
still had like two grand in my pocket,
I didn't have to go to the airport.
So it's like, you know what,
that's kind of cool.
And it's never going to be better than
watching the patriots win their first one
ever be that big of an underdog. So
I haven't gone since. Plus, you know,
I do the road all the time. I'm always
going to the front of the airport,
so it takes a lot. Gosh, I'm an old man
man. I mean he takes a lot to gate two.
I used to work at the
orange bowl as a kid.
I grew up in Miami sorta.
And uh,
I worked as a hot dog salesman at
the orange ball during the dolphins.
I would go to the dolphins getting the
perfect season. I was there for that.
No women 80 hours, like eight years
old. Uh, but my, my mercury Morris.
Oh yeah.
Jim Kicked Larry.
Larry Little Whoa. Keep going.
But offensive guard there.
Jan is pretty good. Uh, Nick
Bond, a county of Connie. Connie.
Uh, who else? Oh, Paul Warfield.
Yes. Gary. All your premium.
Very impressive. Your area. Bob Greasy.
Of course bill Stanfield,
the eight four member that the,
you know the name but a stand
Philip on it. I know all of that.
Just from watching NFL,
like Willie Marlin Briscoe
and the thing people forget,
which I'm glad on some sort of forum I
get to bring up is that that I was there
at the injury. It was a San Diego
Grease when grease he got knocked out,
people forget.
Greasy got knocked out in the third game
of the season and Earl moral took down
all the way to the playoffs and then
greasy came in and closed the deal and he
always had Earl moral gets
remembered for Superbowl three yeah,
more than he does for us.
That Superbowl six.
That one's seven eight I don't
know what number it was. Yeah,
I could actually sit there and
rain man it and throw it out.
I know I could sit here and I remembered
a yeah, in Bay jets, chiefs, Colts,
cowboys, Miami, my boys, my
seven or eight. Wow. Very good.
That's all I did for 10 to seven dolphins
lost and 70 would have been 14 nothing
cause my past ran back. The Gary,
your Pram, me and day you go, Oh God,
that was so I grew up with that and then
I sold hot dogs there and then I sold
hot dogs at the Super Bowl and 78 there.
That was my first one and then
a 78 79 was cowboys. Yeah,
Steelers cowboys.
Of course I was selling hot dogs.
I was stored by the way ever. Oh
yeah, I was there. A cowboys fan,
but I still call fan and I was there
selling hot dogs and it was solely
unregulated. It, what's that
guy's name? Bless his heart.
He's got to be the sickest man in the
building. That guy's lawn, Jackie,
the guy drop the ball. Oh, I don't
know. He played for the cardinals.
He had to show his hands in the business
and then he was so fucking wide open.
He had time to think about it and threw
it at him and he ate. He just dropped it.
I was stoned suddenly. Hot Dog. We used
to get there. We used to get there.
It was so unregulated. There was
no, as in such a bad part of town.
And they would let everyone in and
you'd have to buy your hot dogs.
And I was 15 or something.
I was,
is supposed to be working there and we'd
get stoned and just walk around selling
hot dogs and uh,
and getting high.
And then I remember I sold on hot
talk to Edward Kennedy at that came,
I thought that was the coolest
thing. Teddy Kennedy, Ted Kennedy.
Ted Kennedy was there. I remember I saw
him a hot dog. You were at Superbowl 13.
Yeah, it was stone. Yeah.
You was selling hot dogs and you sold one
to one of the Kennedy, so that's right.
That's pretty cool.
Right.
You people aren't going to go see
walk of shame has Friday. I agree.
That's the best.
Yeah.
So how did you end up playing catch
with Dan Marino in New York City late at
night? Oh Gosh. Yeah,
I know some Marino. Uh,
I met through a golf tournament,
Bobby Kennedy,
Bobby Kennedy charge and try
the Irish Riviera Shriver.
I remember that actor or that actor,
sorry.
That's a horrible way to start
because he's still around.
Still works. DB Sweeney.
Remember DV Sweeney, I remember the
name. Yeah. KTV Sweeney. I know athletes.
I'm not good with Efram. Zimbalist Jr of
course. He was great. He was a kicker.
Yeah. Uh, anyway,
I got to meet Dan and Danny down in
Miami t through this tournament while he
played and uh,
we became friends.
I don't know why it made very little
sense to me that you became friends.
Oh good. There it is. And we
played golf, sold hot dogs.
It's super [inaudible] and I couldn't be
a bigger dolphins fan of Meta marina on.
It's definitely a fan boy.
But he let it go and we sort of became
friends and I would go down and play the
turning away became friends and then he,
oh yeah, he's in this movie. Little Nicky.
I did. Uh Huh. So we call them
in Sandler who loved him to,
uh, call that love. Dan Marino
isn't one. No, he's the best.
I kind of think he's the best. Yeah. You
love him. Yeah. I got to hook you guys up.
Nobody I know. I know. God bless.
Everybody had caught up to him
and he was, I just, you know,
the guy had no fucking running game.
You have a look at it as it's
running backs during the no,
I've said this either way. I have to
admit one horrible thing. Delvin Williams.
Tony, Nathan Abdul Jabbar was
one headache monster. Literally.
Yeah. Is that who it was? Yeah,
like basketball player names.
Oh my God.
Robert Parish.
Kevin Mchale, the uh,
it's so horrible to admit,
but I have to be honest, cause that's
what this is all about. Right? Oh,
I shouldn't lie. No. Hollywood.
I should be completely phony.
I had you on here for me.
Oh, girl thing to do. Right.
I just want you to say how great I
was in the movie. Yeah. You were at,
you were really good.
Uh, but, uh, the, uh,
this is terrible that I went to college
and I wore a bra metaphorically,
and maybe even real,
right in the middle of Merinos heyday.
I was in college and I wasn't a
total like sports or stupid guy,
but part of me, I don't know what
happened. Oh, it's a fee. Yeah.
And I was a film guy and I lived a
hundred yards from Fenway pack and I never
went.
I was into football.
I mean it was in a film and foreign
movies and Ah, I was such a,
what word can I say? Dude?
I was a douche where yet
I was young, but I was an athlete
growing up and something changed.
I smoke Shit Tan, I talk, I use
my hands when I talk. I was,
I cared about movies and I was in the
middle of Boston in 1984 and I didn't go
and then it was me.
I got out of college and I came back.
But they Marino I was aware of and I
watched him. I liked him in college too.
I was aware of him then
and that whole dry,
did you see that documentary on the draft?
Yeah. So good. I just watched it again.
You don't want to start today that
the one that drove me up the wall, uh,
they did a 30 for 30 on the Detroit
Pistons. Oh yeah, yeah. Bad Boys. Yeah,
it was,
it's so fucking funny watching that like,
I mean obviously take all this with a
grain of salt because I am a Celtics fan,
but like just, it's just a
bunch of old men talk and shit.
It's just,
I find,
I find like blame beer out who
actually did shit and those stories.
Stories of brain reserve like a Bobby,
your Larry Bird,
Boston guys. I'm sorry. I'm just
naming other like even like Jordan,
you don't hear,
even though he is a shit talking about
here and like these guys were just like,
the funniest thing was with filthy
players talk about like what they do,
how the way they frame it. They're like,
you know, I always tried to get like,
you know, I was going to win the
mental game. I was going to wait.
And then they like cut to land beer, like
throwing an elbow and somebody spaces.
They're in the air coming down
the way it is. It's just like,
and Laimbeer kept going. You know
somebody had the way that black cat yup.
So me of the way, it's like,
no, you really didn't get,
didn't you could've gone out there and
just play the game and see if you could
one when playing the game and of course
certain mentality and Isaiah was doing
like, you know when they were called
thugs, Isaiah was kind of going,
you know when people, when we, he has
these long pauses, you know, you know,
use a stereotype against you.
You can choose to either fight it on it,
bracing.
It's like dude,
there's no stereotype stereotype there.
This is what you guys were doing.
You were beating the shit out of people.
You took basically the flyers, you
know broad street. Yeah. Basically.
Yeah we can't beat so we're just going
to beat the shit out of you and then
we're going to call it act like
we're playing chess sida. Dude,
you just broke my nose. I mean
your head man, I'm in your head.
I really think we're just,
somethings that fucker took him up and
I'm not talking about real horn because
that guy was seriously, I would not, I
mean obviously I wouldn't fuck with any,
what does that guy look was the real deal.
But the rest of them though,
when they want, when they find
out, when the Bulls beat him,
they didn't shake the hands. They just
came off like a bunch of punks. Oh yeah.
Yeah. They will punky.
That was terrible. And,
and people will talk about Vinnie Johnson.
We'll talk about Bella check walking
off at the end of the Superbowl, uh,
when we were undefeated and then we
weren't, but that was also the same thing.
That was embarrassing as a patriots fan
to watch that it will be a fucking man y
cross. They beat you. Yeah.
Hey, congratulations. You
about it. Then you won't go.
Yeah, yeah, that's switching. But I dunno,
it's just that reminded me of the
University of Miami one where the cow is
brutal, where they just go and like, you
know, the whole country afraid of us.
I was like, dude, I was in a professional
football city. I don't even remember.
I remember hearing you guys were doing
things, but I wasn't sitting by my phone.
Shivering. I know it's a
football team. Oh God. Yeah.
So I told him off on a rant. So
Dan Marino? No, that's funny.
The enforcers, how they'll say it's a
mental game, just trying to get a mental,
it's like,
Oh really?
So Bob Probers and McSorley had that
little mental edge where they were just
like, hit you with a stick over
that Colbert problem or was good.
That's not the right one. Yeah, he's
the wrong guy. Die By the way. Yeah.
So they all died one time.
I know we can tell sports stories and I
got to remember all the names I played
in this hockey tournament cause I, you
know, I wrote those mighty ducks movies.
I'm like, yeah, well you know I
created that hockey team. Cut me out.
I'll get the mental edge
at all. Nice. I am dirty.
My favorite player is Kenny Lindeman.
So don't fuck with me though.
I'll fucking hook you in ways you didn't
even know. Could you could be hooked in.
Yeah, but that guy, I don't
consider it was like a dirty plan.
That's awesome. Do you think
that he was so dirty? Feet dirty?
Shippy dirty this Chinos Sorelli
but then there's blow your knee out and
your career that really like Matt Cook.
Oh as he calls it, finishing
his checks. Oh yeah.
Fucking hunter.
Uh Oh damn hundred Jesus Christ.
That guy should have gone
out on the ice with a sickle.
That guy who's like literally like
a sociopath when he would do shit.
What was the scariest thing about
him is when you looked at him,
when he was in the penalty box,
there wasn't an ounce of remorse.
The comfort that I take with
a lot of those guys, cause
they have that, you know,
look, I did what I had to do. That
Bill Romanowo ski kind of thing.
All you do is you're just like,
thank God they're not working in a
corporation that has some stuff that they
need to get rid of was
because those guys would,
with their helmet hockey helmet on, would
pour it into the drinking water course.
I'm going a little big here, but no,
it's, it's, yeah, it's like frightening.
Yeah. Anyway, she were in New
York City with Dan Marino.
It's about four o'clock in the morning.
Somehow.
You have a football after a Knicks game.
Got To toss it around in the street.
He had just retired in the, uh, you
wanted to chuck it. He's the best guy.
Cause he's like, I want to throw, I want
to chuck it. Or you just like throw it.
I love throwing to, there's no
better feeling. And uh, yeah,
after next outside the region, uh,
the, the hotel and uh, whatever.
I'm upper east side took us 60,
64th street or something like that and
there's nobody really on the streets.
And Dan Marino was out there.
Yeah,
just throwing balls that look like painted
like a punt and you're running under
pressure sneakers, sneakers. But uh, yeah,
there's nothing like a
pro athlete thrown ball.
It's just so different. I mean, I
can throw a spiral in something,
but it's like just that then
right in your hands. So great. Oh,
it's literally cutting through the
end. Oh yeah. Yeah. Have you, Oh,
you've been out on the sideline and stuff.
You see the difference?
It's like sat close enough to the game.
Look Dude,
I'll go to like of division three,
college football game and you can blow
me away with my athletic abilities.
But like I did something earlier this
year for inside the NFL at the pro bowl
talking about my imdv page here, but
I saw 'em I'm not go well, you know,
I know all the old guys. I don't all
the young guys who, who, who's he?
Amazing athlete from Dez
Bryant. Yeah, I saw him.
Um, they were just basically doing like
some walk through practice, you know,
it's the pro bowl,
so you know,
the kind of joking around and stuff and
he was playing catch with somebody and
do, first of all the guys
like physique was like,
I couldn't draw a guy in
better shape. Does Brian? Yeah,
he looked like a superhero, right? Yeah.
And they're throwing the
ball to him and he was,
he was kind of letting it almost go past
him and then he was just reaching down
and catching it.
Yeah.
The way I would like a balloon that was
floating through slowly is catching a,
yeah,
like three quarters speed football.
He would catch it and then he did this
thing that almost looked like a butterfly
knife. Right. He would flip it around
and it would be in the throwing position.
It would go around the back of his hand
that says front of the Senate and in the
same motion he was bringing it back and
we'd zip it back to this says could this
little bald white guy coach it would
you know you saw the pain every time you
caught. I know Dez is catch and I just
saw that these guys, they have big hands,
but that's one thing I must say. I
go, they're great athletes and stuff,
but when you have huge mitts and you've
shows Shite shuck in these guys' hands,
that helps. I don't have big hands.
I'm not saying I could have been a pro,
but I think it's the only
thing that stop gestures.
Like I read your scout raging bull,
raging bull.
I think this is what it
was because I had my hands.
He had hands like a little
girl or a baby or something.
That's why I could never be a heavyweight
fighter. But I, yeah, I, my hands have,
have, have totally kept me back
in many ways. They're not huge.
What age did they stop growing?
Things stop growing when
I stop growing, you know,
in about 20 but whatever, it makes
a difference. I mean hockey too.
You ever play like,
you know someone who has big hands,
they hold the sticky
keys and feel and put,
I don't have the leverage
that if only I had, I was,
I was a big kid the fullest right
up until about fourth grade. Right?
Like I was supposed to be born June 10th,
1968 I was born June 24 19 I was like,
no.
I came out through,
I was like a 10 pound baby.
There's not one cute picture of Moma.
Irish was the same size of giant white.
I look like I should have been walking
through a little city just knocking shit
down.
I wrote that baby fat till about fifth
grade plus I stayed back in first grade,
so I had an extra year on people.
Then around sixth grade there was always
that kid who caught puberty, you know,
a couple of times where you have all
of a sudden guys are getting like peach
fuzz in the eighth grade.
And like I was a late bloomer
and then after that I was like,
I better stop being more funny or
now so I was, I was never a, uh,
a force to be reckoned with
after fourth or fifth grade.
Once the NERF football
was out of the game. Um,
it's like when they
took away the red line,
I was just too slow for
the whole phone thing.
So did you start skating at a young
age? Was that your thing? No, no.
I actually didn't take the game up.
Uh,
like getting pads and actually really
trying to get good at it until I moved out
here. Oh really? Yeah, because
you know, you've got to come
up from a hockey family,
you're going to get up at four in
the morning, 4:30 AM last time.
Cutting up orange slices
and shit, whatever the fuck
it is they do. And uh, my,
my family was Midwest people that
moved. Oh. So they were more, uh,
you know, baseball, football,
yeah. Not even like basketball,
baseball, football. Yeah.
So, um, oh, so you play
hockey out here now? I, we,
we had a great group of guys like
comics that were playing. Oh yeah.
And um, and I was, I was the
guy who organized in the game.
I got a little busy on the road and
then somebody else took it over.
And you know,
what happened was a bunch of people heard
about it and at first it started off
was fucking like bad news bears,
right. I was out there, I had a helmet,
gloves and skates sets it. And
like, I was falling on the ice,
like getting bruised so bad. They
weren't showing up for like three days.
I'd be in the shower and I sudden look
like somebody came the back of my fucking
fight. And so then I, you
know, I started like, you know,
I bought all this stuff and then
everybody was all suited up.
And what happened was all of a sudden
these rink rat started showing up.
Oh that game's sped up.
And everybody who sucked,
stop coming. Right? Saying
it wasn't fun. That's,
I was the only guy I stuck it out
and I went from being apoe, apoe,
shitty to the word immediately,
like the worst.
Why are you even, I mean I look literally
like a fan that ran out on the ice.
Like that's how much slower I was.
But I did learn to change direction
pretty quickly because every time when I
would finally catch up with everybody,
we've been going the other way.
So I learned how to stop on both sides.
I burned a lot of calories first.
Well there is nothing more fun
that even if you're bad at hockey,
because I played it as a kid and then
moved out here in 86 or something.
And then the Gretzky got traded down here
and I became a hockey fan again cause
we would go to the games and hang out.
We had nothing else to do.
We go to the Games and then I remembered,
I used to skate as a kid and I loved it.
And I lived in Culver city and there was
a skating rink literally a mile away.
And I live with this. That's closing down,
you know, I know, I know. That sucks.
That was my place. I live
with this guy, Pete Berg,
this director acting now and I lived
together and we just got Wahlberg movie,
right? Yeah, yeah. Lone survivor. We
were amazing. Yeah. We were loser.
Nothing to do or we just go to the skating
rink and skate around in circles all
day because he was from New York and
we used to play pee wee and it was like
fucking, what's that movie
where they skated around and
walked around and serve a
midnight express.
That's how we spent our days.
Like just go into the circle and going,
what are you doing in la?
And then kids like free air
conditioning too. That's also true.
It was a middle of the summer in Culver
City, California and no prospects,
nothing. And, uh, so we
started skating again and uh,
that inspired me to do
mighty ducks doing that.
Like seeing kids come in
like little fucking, uh,
rink rats would come in and I was like,
Ooh,
I want to know where to
move you about kids' hockey.
I used to play kid's hockey and
that's how that all started.
And so I got into hockey that way.
Then all those movies and I got to
fulfill every hockey dream in the world,
you know,
cause you might x became a franchise of
a hockey team that I named and then I
just took advantage of
everything I got to go.
And they went from ducks to mighty ducks?
No.
What do you mean it was the
other way around? Sorry.
Yeah, it was a little upset because
uh, yeah, no, I liked, I actually,
when they first made it mighty ducks,
I thought that was stupid
because I was a sports fan first.
Even though it was my name, I was like,
I totally understood. I go, really?
That's so the mighty ducks.
I loved it as the franchise and the name
and I had to suit Disney for doing what
they did. But when as a
hockey purists and then, yeah.
And you suit Disney,
you at super bowl 13 high selling
hotdogs to Ted Kennedy. Yeah.
Yeah. Tempt me. Which never
happened a lot by the way.
I remember he gave me like $2 and
it was a dollar fraud or 75% tip.
Yeah, no, of course. Yeah, that was cool.
So, uh, what, what else? Your resume,
you played catch with Dan Marino
and played hockey with, you know,
everyone you can imagine
faced off against Gretzky.
Yeah, I did that. But listen to this,
I played in the last game in the Boston
Garden in a celebrity hockey match
before they tore it down.
It just happened to be like the last
thing they did in the Boston Garden was a
stupid celebrity hockey match with us
against no way against the old Bruins,
like the alumni Bruins,
which is a very active organization
to like the flyers that Bruins.
And so we sat in the Bruins locker room,
me and the stupid celebrities,
I'm barely a celebrity
because of the hockey thing.
I was able to suck up to it and become,
and I had Bobby or come in and give
us a speech, uh, in the locker room.
He was making fun of it,
but he started giving us a speech about
how he to go out there and fucking kick
ass and everything.
And he, he got into it.
Everyone was drunk as shit and we went
out and played against the Bruins alumni.
Oh, you told me that everyone was dying
laughing like, oh you always hilarious.
Same Week. We got to win this
period. Yeah. It was the best.
And I had a shootout against
Reggie Lanolin, et cetera.
Ice with the place was packed to lost
the garden and I scored and I swear he,
Reggie was trying, he stacked the
pads on. I went, okay. So that was it.
That was my favorite experience of all
my, yeah, put that on a resume. Jesus.
Craigo yeah, I could win an academy
award. Well, not likely, but if I did,
I liked the lovely Forrest Gump,
like slash make a wish life dude.
That's, yeah. It's fun to be able to do
those things. Yeah. That's the best part.
Yeah. Jesus. Steve. Yeah. And
I don't know. I don't know
where to go from here. Well,
we don't have to go anywhere.
I think it goes back or go
home and watch Wonka shame.
I think that's absolutely brilliant.
I hope more movies do that. They are,
although I still love going to the
movie theater, uh, and I, you know,
a sentimental jackass. It'll upset me
because eventually, you know, I mean,
I don't know whether,
yeah. Eventually, you know,
that's going to be the way it's going to
be done. What? I just saw movies, I think,
I know,
I think to know that that's like saying
that everybody thought like the LP,
the vinyl was going to go away.
Yeah.
There'll be people there
always be hipsters and people
like that and sentimental
fools like me that will still
want to go to the movies. Yes.
And then bitch about people
talking and all that stuff.
And movie theaters are evolving
and will evolve into a,
I think a cool cooler experience. They
just will the, the seats and everything.
Other people,
I mean,
it was a great place to take when you
didn't have a license to take a girl and
being alone with it. Oh yeah. Right.
It was fucking awesome. Never. Yeah.
Are the balconies they had, you
can't watch it now, you know,
at your parents' house.
No,
but am I basically saying it's very hard
to go to third base at your sister's
house? They Sisters House Jesus
Christ girlfriend's house. Yeah.
Yeah. It's hard to go to third base and
movie theaters too. We can't end on that.
No. Okay. That's somebody
complaining. All right.
Anyways, listen to it. I, uh, I had such
a good time, whether I'm in it or not,
you're totally in any out or not or
whether it's fucking hilarious whether you
were metaphorically saying, you know,
you're talking about your grandmother,
but actually talking about
me that I was cut out.
I still had an awesome time and I got to,
got to meet some great people.
I just still, every once in a while
reach out to, uh, Ethan play. God,
he's fucking hilarious. So, uh, all your
stuff's in there. I hope so. Yeah. Well,
whatever you yelling at the kid, nothing
funnier than bill burr yelling at a kid.
Shut the fuck up. Yeah. Right there.
That's probably the biggest
selling point to my lists of stone.
So great to see you again. Let's
take the women out here and we'll go.
We will at some point. All right.
All right. That is the, uh, the,
the bonus episode of the Monday morning
podcast. Thank you so much for listening.
And please check out walk of shame Friday,
May 2nd at the theaters,
or you can down it on a downtown it.
Download it on iTunes.
Yeah. All right. That's it. All right,
buddy. Thank you. Thank you. Bye.